[Music]
okay everyone this is my spoiler-free
review of the newest batman film the
batman
now
you see all these great critics scores
are coming out around tomatoes for it
and it got me more hype but i still had
to keep my expectations in check here i
was so excited and disclaimer i'm not
someone part of the snyder verse i'm not
like this snyder head i'm not a big fan
of zack snyder in general i think the
only film i've liked that he's directed
was watchmen
i am not a christopher nolan head either
i have no bias here i'm going in this
just looking at as a film as it is so
what i did to prepare was watch all of
matt reeves's filmography before i did
this review and
you know i have
similar issues i have with his recent
plan of the apes film
in this movie that
the thing with matt reeves directing to
me is he frustrates me as a director
because i feel like he's in too into his
own head where he's in love with his
work obsessed with his work but it's
plotting along and he doesn't have a
good awareness of pace and where it
needs to tighten up and that could go to
the editor too right so this movie
just keep your expectations to check
because it is slow and
it's long and that's fine i like that it
was long because we've seen it pulled
off recently with spiderman no way home
but the difference with spiderman only
home in this is that spiderman knowing
home from the beginning to the end i was
engaged i felt so many emotions were
here didn't really feel anything and i
checked my phone to see what time was a
couple times which is crazy uh and that
shouldn't be happening right
and
it's frustrating that this is the case
and to compare despair with no way home
because that's the most recent big
superhero movie that everyone was going
to see you know that movie has about 10
moments where the whole audience is
clapping and shouting this movie has two
people saying it's better than dark
knight are out of their minds uh it's
nowhere near the dark knight and
it's not even as good as batman begins
it's better than the dark knight rises
i'll give it that but
it has things where you want more it
feels like it's so reserved and laid
back that it never really takes off
and i do like the performances here i
love paul dano as a riddler he does the
best dynamic performance i think
penguin's solid with colin farrell here
but he's not in it much
i do think though that zoe kravitz and
robert patterson do the job well they're
good but there's not any dynamic element
to their performances i think they're
very one note and that's disappointing
but they're still good like i enjoy it
and it's more of the writing i think
that hurts this film for me and that's
the problem too i'm talking about just
moments people clap there's nothing
memorable from this film for me and this
isn't a spoiler but one scene that was
amazing to me that was probably one that
i thought was amazing but still not that
memorable as you see in the trailers
with the penguin and the car chase the
batman that was awesome but that's
another issue i have speaking of
trailers is that a lot of stuff in the
trailer
spoils story beats that are really
important that they actually affect the
scenes while you're watching because you
kind of know what's going to happen
because of the trailers so that was also
concerning and that's a problem with the
marketing there can't really hold that
against the movie i do like this broken
version of batman i do like what they
were going for but i think he gets
obsessed with making sure it's a
detective version of batman which is
obviously the original
full-on detective comics dc here with
batman but it's too obsessed with it
where it forgets it's even
bruce wayne or a superhero movie and it
gets bogged down in crime jargon too
much that it just feels incredibly slow
and plotting and that it's not as clever
as it thinks it is everything i've seen
here before and
that's really just disappointing at the
end of the day but again
i think that there's a lot of good
happening here and it's just a good
movie and i think what's frustrating
when you watch it is you see so much
potential with the talent involved that
that's why i'm selling all these
criticisms is because
it makes it just okay and i think it's
brought down by the directing and by the
script which is really really
disappointing so i'm giving this one a
7.9 because again the other day it's
still a solid film and it does a lot
right with
tone right there's some stuff i'm really
trying not to spoil anything but there's
some stuff you'll see in the beginning i
like that i wish they did more in the
middle and again it really just suffers
from not being super engaging but it's
got its moments with the action and the
fighting but still could be better
everything in this could be better you
know and i think even the score is
overrated and they repeat the main theme
a lot they do it to death and you're
going to hear a lot of the same nirvana
song that you've heard in the trailer
and it's just repetitive so yeah the
more to talk about the more frustrated i
am with it but again i don't even know
how to put into words but it's still
worth seeing it's still solid it's not a
mess like some of these snyder batman
films but it's just not amazing it's
just good it just holds back so let me
know if you plan on seeing it i read
every comment and try to respond as many
as i can give me all your thoughts when
you do see it i also have a spoiler
review that's out already so you can
check that out after you've seen it or
if you want to spoil yourself go right
ahead and please follow me at steve
barley show on twitter instagram tic tac
for more of me and i'll see you next
time